Wow when they get to trenzalore the
console room blew up so big it was I was
back on the enterprise Oh Star Trek fans
get what I was on about with that Hekla
that don't linger all right folks
the name of the doctor at the end of
series seven nearly the end of Matt
Smith's run boy this has been this has
been a trip so this was one I was
curious see what my thoughts on him
we're gonna be because at the time that
it aired I liked it a lot but a lot of
that had to do with two things that I'm
not gonna say might necessarily my
opinions have changed on but they have
evolved one was it was very much sold at
the time it aired on the promise of the
war doctor of John Hurt and well I at
least to my memory day the doctor is
still pretty good he is not necessarily
the highlight of it and at this point
having heard the war doctor Big Finish
series and being very underwhelmed by it
that promise doesn't carries much weight
now as it did at the time it aired and
the other thing was at the time I didn't
really fully think about the complete
implications of what they did with Clara
and I was kind of prepared to move on
from them until stuff went on in the
next series that really kind of made me
go oh I should have realized what was
going on here but even with all that in
place I still think this is pretty good
I think this is solid in a number of
areas I think this is definitely one of
the better stories that Jenny strikes a
vastra are on I mentioned
a couple episodes ago that as much as I
like them as characters they aren't in
that many good stories this is one of
the better ones that they're in it's
nice to have river back it feels
appropriate and I found myself thinking
do I buy it the idea that after the
doctor sort of put her in the you know
or her the memory of her I guess
into the library computer that he never
went back him visited her and I tried to
think on that Ike's and partly wanted to
go that doesn't seem right but then
another part of me went well the thing
is and this was something that classic
era Doctor Who just never really
addressed but modern era doctor who has
established that doctor doesn't really
go back for people once you know they
have their initial time with him so yeah
I suppose I I do have to I do have to
swallow that one it is consistent I
don't love it but it is consistent I
can't claim otherwise on that Matt Smith
does some great work here he does a
really good job with this sort of sense
of dread and fear and regret that the
doctor is experiencing throughout pretty
much this whole story that's really good
there are a couple logical leaps like
the random guy in Victorian era London
why did he know anything about the
whisper men or the doctor but who was
this guy why didn't he know any hey I
don't know I feel like there might have
been like a prequel thing that
established why he knew stuff but I
didn't feel like digging it up and it's
the kind of thing that unless you go I
unless you go out of your way to
ancillary things that goes unanswered if
it's even answered there I'm working off
memory here on that but I actually
really really really like the great
intelligence in this I think this is a
fantastic payoff for the great
intelligence especially as he's been
depicted in the modern air
so there's a couple things I like about
this there's some things that I like in
general concept I think that if they
were gonna do this with any character at
all the great intelligence works for it
and ultimately it gets sold by Richard
e-grants performance so I like the idea
there's okay
lay back up there's a plenty of villains
of all stripes who hate the doctor
whether it is complete races of people
like the Daleks whether it is
individuals like the master lots of
people have a lot of reasons to really
hate the doctor and to want him dead or
to suffer but the thing is they pretty
much always have other plans and then
the doctor shows up in like oh I'm gonna
kill him but they have something else
that they're working towards and the
great intelligence has had that up to
this point but where he comes in on this
story we realize that he has nothing
left but spite I like the idea that it's
not just a matter of he's willing to let
plans fall apart just to you know take
on the doctor but the idea is him
succeeding involves him dying and he's
willing to pay that price to make the
doctor suffer that level of hatred of I
can't even deal with the fact that you
have stopped me over and over again
anymore that's it I don't even care
about everything else I was working
towards you are going down and that is a
concept that I like in general but work
wires a core performance to sell it and
Richard e-grant sells it that scowl that
Gower from him
oh that completely sells the loathing
that this entity has for the doctor
totally buy it completely works I really
really do like him I do think he's
he's a part of this story that I don't
think gets the credit he deserves I
think it's surprising amount hinges on
that performance selling that level of
hatred and I think he does do that
so all right let's talk about Clara the
first thing I'll say is for the purposes
of this story the whole concept and what
they're doing it's kind of neat right I
mean it's all it's a little weird and
bonkers but like that's kind of nifty
the problem is and this gets reiterated
unfortunately multiple times in the next
series but we'll burn those bridges when
we get to them it starts this recurring
theme of Clara basically being the
single most amazing person or most
meaningful person or most significant
person the doctor has ever known or ever
traveled with and just putting it
broadly philosophically I don't think
any companion has any business being
asserted by the show and by the text of
the narrative to be that vital much like
I don't think the doctor should be the
most important thing in the universe I
don't think any one companion should be
the most important thing in his life and
this combined with listen combined with
hellbent really does create a recurring
motif of Clara is the most important
companion he will ever have and it even
starts with when she first shows up and
this idea of all she did to endear
herself to her was to him was basically
exist
she didn't have to do anything he took
her on board because she was a mystery
so already she's the most fascinating
girl in existence and now she's the most
important because literally across his
entire timeline
she kept saving him now this is probably
the least egregious of the episodes I've
met
that have this going on in them so we'll
recur with this but the thing is the
reason it's less egregious is because
we're in a bit of a recursive time loop
here where there's an argument to be
made that even though
Clara's words are I've always been there
there's still an argument that you can
make that she both was and wasn't always
there because the only reason she was
there was to maintain the timeline as it
existed so the doctor still always did
what the doctor was always going to do
it's just she prevented all the damage
or corrected all the damage that the
great intelligence did so even though
she crops up across his entire history
saving him at every incarnation it's not
like the doctor would have died without
her like it like in the abstract the
doctor would have died had she not
prevented this guy who was messing with
the timeline so the doctor still gets to
have all his accomplishments and they
are still his look I don't know if what
I'm saying is little too mind-bending
okay let's bring it down to a specific
example you're the first doctor getting
in the TARDIS now as presented it makes
it seem like the only reason he gets
into the turist that he does is because
Clara tells him to accept that through
the nature of the time loop there's an
argument that he actually always did get
in the correct TARDIS and he was getting
into the wrong TARDIS because of
something the great intelligence did and
then Clara just corrected it so what's
the chicken and the egg did he get the
TARDIS that he did only because of Clara
or did he always get the TARDIS that he
did and she just preserved that I lean
towards that one especially because
that's way more comfortable for me in
terms of what I'm okay with going on in
terms of her placing and level of
importance so even though this
plays into something that I hate
it's the later instances that really
grind my gears this one I can work with
and it was kind of nice to go back and
re-watch it and realize like no this
it's a little bit like how when when
I've said and I even mentioned kids that
I really don't like how the doctors
importance just keeps getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and like
he's he's like the savior of the
universe and the universe knows it he's
like the most powerful being and he's a
thing of legend across like a how I hate
that you can go back to earlier views in
the overdue Doctor Who series and see me
talk about things like the Pandorica
opens or even before that with things
like silence in the library and the
forest of the Dead where there were
moments where the doctor did Bank on his
own reputation but those moments worked
for me it was just later on as it kept
happening and got bigger and bigger
further down the line that it really
bothered me that's kind of where I am
with this thing with Clara here
encapsulated in the name of the doctor I
actually think it works or at least it
works well enough for me it's what we're
gonna get her later on that's really
gonna drive me up the wall
so I think that's pretty much everything
that I had to say on this performances
are solid it's that I have nitpicks on
the script but for the most part it's
pretty good I think the idea of the tart
is starting to break down and then the
bigger on the inside leaks to the
outside that's kind of a cool idea and
overall I think this is solid the
whisper men are sort of unnecessary um I
mean I guess to some degree they needed
a physical threat from the great
intelligence I'm not sure was that vital
but for the most part this all works it
hangs together pretty well and I was
nervous to come back and re-watch it
because I thought since I know stuff is
gonna go on later that really bothers me
is this gonna now fall apart it doesn't
I still like this
so the name of the doctor that my
friends is the end of overdue Doctor Who
because this is the last episode of the
modern era of Doctor Who that I did not
already have a video up for but fear not
because I'm gonna continue the rewatch
overdue Doctor Who starting next week
will become take to Doctor Who review as
I reira view episodes that I actually
have already done reviews of previously
so don't worry we're still going through
it so come on back and stick around
in the meantime whatever your thoughts
on the name of the doctor drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
whole bunch of stuff to do you know what
it is and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]